[Musique]
légal général de mardi prochain pourrait
être très suivi en tout cas cette
journée d'action pour la défense des
retraites mobilise les syndicats il faut
s'attendre à de nombreux désagréments
notamment dans le domaine des transports
en commun de très nombreux secteurs vont
être touchés 80% des vols annulés at on
appris hier côté sncf de grosses
perturbations attendent sans compter
l'appel à la grève des enseignants voici
le détail françois beaudonnet florence
qui font
ils sont venus de toute la france 200
enseignants en grève depuis plusieurs
semaines contre la réforme de
l'éducation nationale et contre celle
des retraites je vais partir à la
retraite au delà de 2020 donc il faut
rajouter
jusqu'à 68 ans puisque j'ai commencé à
travailler à 26 ans et je partirai avec
38 % de mon salaire net
aujourd'hui ils sont donc venus
également préparer le 13 mai ce jour là
une semaine après leur manifestation à
paris les enseignants devraient se
joindre massivement au bataillon des
grévistes mais ce mardi sera surtout
noire dans les transports avec un trafic
ferroviaire fortement perturbé dès lundi
soir pour les trains de nuit mardi la
sncf prévoit 1 tgv sur 3 en moyenne peu
ou pas de corail de ter en revanche
l'eurostar circulera normalement de très
grosses difficultés également dans le
ciel les syndicats d'air france mais
surtout ceux des contrôleurs aériens
appellent eux aussi à cesser le travail
conséquence 80% des vols seront annulés
dans les aéroports français toutes
compagnies confondues aller au bureau on
lèvera aussi du véritable casse tête le
trafic des autobus sera perturbée dans
60 à 70 villes de province dont
marseille toulouse lyon ou encore
bordeaux à paris il faudra sûrement
marché à la ratp métro et rer et bus
seront rares et la circulation inégale
selon les lignes
seule petite consolation pour ceux qui
décideront tout de même de voyager mardi
sur les autoroutes les employés en grève
pourrait organiser des opérations péages
gratuits
[Musique]